telomere length maintenance okay thank
you very much I would tell you some of
the stories some stories related to t
rumors that we are doing in the lab and
I apologize because I'm a wet biology's
so I'm not going to give a lot of
algorithms and I hope that what I say is
clear enough and if not just ask me so
two numbers are at the ends of the
linear chromosomes and they are made up
of proteins and DNA the DNA are simple
repeats and the proteins are there to
protect the ends and give them a special
shape in order to ensure that the tumors
can carry out their two main functions
okay so one of the main functions is the
following each time a cell divides
duplicates its DNA we are losing a
little bit of information from the end
of the chromosome and this is a it's
called it's it's a fact okay and after a
certain number of cell divisions the
cells siness and die this is called the
high freq limit and actually gives a
limit to the number of cell divisions
that the cell can undergo a somatic cell
in our body so this sounds very sad that
actually it's a very important
anti-cancer mechanism because this allow
does not allow the cells to grow
indefinitely you have to do a certain
number of cell divisions and then you
stopped however there are situations for
example in embryos in which you have to
do a lot of cell divisions okay if you
think about the diss periment and the
egg you make a zygote and now you have
to make a baby okay so it's a lot of
divisions and so in in dose in those
situations you need some way of
elongating the telomeres and there is a
special enzyme called telomerase which
is really really special it's a reversal
script is that means it's an enzyme that
takes RNA and makes it into DNA and it
uses its own template to do that it
works something like this if you have at
the end of a chromosome okay you see the
repeats telomerase will come and use its
own green RNA as
template to synthesize one repeat and
then move aside synthesize another
repeat move aside synthesize another
repeat and so on and so forth and
eventually you have to synthesize the
other strand of the DNA and this is done
by the regular machinery that
synthesizes DNA so we know that
telomerase is active in embryos it turns
out that if you are a cancer cell and
you want to live forever the first thing
that you have to do is to make sure that
you have enough telomeres to be able to
live forever and in about eighty percent
of the cases as we heard yesterday there
is a resuscitation if you want of
telomerase so telomerase is usually
repressed at birth so in our somatic
cells we don't have telomerase but in in
cancer cells in about eighty percent of
the cases we get reactivation of
telomerase and in about twenty percent
of the cases there is an alternative
mechanism based on recombination that
maintains genomics the second important
role for telomeres is to make sure that
the cell does not repair them as if they
were a broken chromosome if you think
about the broken chromosome and you
think about the telomere they look
exactly the same there is no difference
at the DNA level however if you would
try to repair something that doesn't
need repair you will actually made a
mess out of the cells okay so you will
start fusing chromosomes chromatids and
you would get a lot of genomic
instability which eventually will bring
two more cancer this is a very good
mechanism that cancer cells use to
actually generate more variability what
is quite striking is that and this is
relative to the go annotation and they
and the things that you can find in the
literature that many of the enzyme that
are required to repair a double strand
break are the same enzymes that at
telomeres are required to prevent the
repair of the double strand break okay
so whenever you get some kind of go term
it doesn't really mean that you
understand what what they go term the
gas or how it is related to a certain
disease and the logic is not automatic
let's go okay so we work with yeast
which gives us all the goods
things in life as you know this is the
same es that gives bread and beer
croissant and but most importantly for
this talk yeast cells have expressed
telomerase and so they are like
embryonic cells or immortal cells new
cancer cells and we would like to really
we are asking really really basic
questions and one of the great things of
yeast is that you can really use it to
ask basic questions that it's very hard
to answer in other systems so the basic
question is how is telomere length
regulated we know that there are
mechanisms such as telomerase that
elongates the telomeres and there are
other nucleases for example that with
shortened telomeres and we know that
each one of them is regulated by other
regulators and there are all kinds of
mechanisms that keep the omen status of
the of the length so for example we
already know and again i apologize i'm
not going to enter into all the details
but there is a bunch of proteins like
prop one that binds chido murs and
actually measures the length of the
telomere and if and then there are some
proteins that bind to the binding
protein and repress or help recruiting
the telomerase so if the tumors are very
long you have a repression and you don't
recruit telomerase and with the
different with the cell divisions you
lose the length of the pyramids if you
got too short now you can recruit more
telomerase and elongate and so the
reason of your status so some time ago
we we took advantage of the fact that in
yeast we have a collection of all the
possible mutants okay so we have six
thousand genes and we have six thousand
strengths each one with a mutation in a
different gene and so we screened all
these mutants for all the mutants that
have an effect on telomere length and we
were looking for either short telomers
or length or long telomeres and we call
these mutants tlm for telomere length
maintenance and you can see here that
it's easy to recognize the last fragment
so this is a southern blot but it
doesn't really matter you are we are
measuring the tumors and since we are
measuring telomeres in a population of
cells each one with many many telomeres
we get the distribute
but it's very easy to see that the wild
type has always the same size of
telomere length and you can find mutants
to have shorter telomeres and those that
have longer to demers so when we did
this for several collections we have the
collection of the non-essential JS
collections of essential genes in that
case we need some genetic trick because
we cannot make a deletion of the gene
and we finish having about 400 genes
that when you mutate each one of them
individually you get either log T rumors
or short illness now I would like to
make sure that you understand it's not
that we are saying that there are 400
proteins sitting at the end of each
telomere what I'm saying is that there
are genes in the genome that when you
mutate them they affect telomere length
it could be direct it could be indirect
good there are many many possibilities
so when you look at the list of the
jeans you know 400 genes is a lot of
jeans and you have essentially anything
that you were expecting two things that
have to do with DNA metabolism chromatin
configuration protein modifications RNA
etcetera etcetera but also a lot of
surprises for on one hand we we get many
many genes for which we know the
function but we have no idea how this
function FX sillerman length for example
sorry the corner transport is one of the
most enriched groups in our universe set
but we don't know why it affects
cedarburg length and we get many many
genes for which either we don't know
what they do or we think we know what
they do but makes no sense that they
affect you more length okay so what do
we know what do we do if you have 400
genes that you're interested in so you
can do one of two are we what what I
call the vertical approach which is you
take genes that you are interested in
usually p53 and then so you threw away
throw away all the list of 400 and you
concentrate on one or two and you
analyze what they do where do they act
how do they act how they are regulated
and so on what do I call the vertical
view but it's it used to be called
molecule
genetics of ocular biology or you can do
the horizontal view which is to to get a
systems view to see how the information
flows within the system how many
pathways you can recognize how are the
jeans organized and so on so we're
trying to do both so for the system
level approach you can you know we are
talking we are working with yeast there
is a lot of information about these
there are genome-wide analysis of
genetic interactions genome-wide
analysis of protein interactions you
name it and so we can use that vast
amount of data and if you take for
example all the 400 genes that are
involved in telomere length maintenance
and you use that data you get a very
clear picture of how telomere length is
being regulated so obviously it's not a
simple thing okay so we are trying in in
several different ways to try to
organize these 400 genes into pathway so
into regulatory units and so today I'm
going to tell you some of the things
that we are doing the work I'm going to
talk today today is was initiated by the
early or is an md/phd student that
finished already and you see that it's a
very serious neurosurgeon actually today
he's a neurosurgeon and with together
with Linda and vera and the basic idea
here was to do an epic sizes analysis
okay so this is how geneticists have
worked for years but of course with one
gene or two genes or three genes you
make a double mutant and you compare the
double mutant with individual single
mutants and you say the following if the
double mutant is worse off than the
single mutants that means that there is
an additive effect and they are probably
working in separate pathways and you can
actually formalize this in a
mathematical way so if there are two
different pathways you can you can say
okay if I effect if I make the double
mutant and I measure for example
telomere length I can expect that the
double mutant will have a stronger
effect than each one of the single
mutants and if they are in the same
pathway the moment I already not
out one of the two mutants then I
inactivated the pathways so the second
mutation should not have any effect and
I will have a number which is larger
from what I would expect from
Independence and of course there are
several situations in which the synergy
for example when there are this
competition or overlapping pathways and
so in that case you may have a surprise
and when you do the double mutant you
get the phenotype that is much much
stronger even little than what you would
expect for a single mutant okay and
usually this approach is carried out for
fitness okay so you can do it with
different organisms and yeast usually
you measure the size of the colony and
you use it for genetic interactions we
apply this for actually the telomere
length itself okay yes could it also be
attitude okay so we we did it both ways
because it's it's a theoretical thing so
we can actually compare so what we do is
actually we compare the observed versus
the expected and we can expect to be
multiplicative or weeks we can expect it
to be added okay and in both cases the
results are very very similar we
couldn't distinguish between the two
models so essentially what we would
really like to do is to take the 400
genes 400 mutants and do the matrix of
400 by 400 double mutants right so this
is only a hundred and sixty thousand
double mutant so I said to a you're okay
go ahead just now take the hundred and
sixty thousand double mutants extract
DNA make triplicate you know DNA
preparation thousands and he looked at
me well we are from the Middle East he
looked at me and he said I'm willing to
do too and I said okay well you you
don't have to do the hundred and sixty
thousand you can do only half of them
because it's symmetrical you can do only
80,000 in triplicates and we are done
three and in that very systematic and
highly scientific way we arrived to the
conclusion that we want to
to a matrix of about 40 by 40 okay and
at the beginning we were very naive and
we were doing actually long mutants
together with short butan so we were
crossing everybody by everybody and then
we discovered that we couldn't make
sense out of the results because in many
cases you cross for example a long
Newton with a short mutant and you get a
wild-type length and you don't really
know whether this is a some genetic
result you know double suppression or
this is a mathematical result one adds
something the other one takes out
something or so we decided to go for the
long mutant separately and for the short
notice separately so for example 40 by
40 long mutants is 1600 and you won't
believe it but he did it in triplicate
so we have we run a southern blot with
markers for size and we can run the
triplicates of the double mutants and
the single mutant that we recreate each
time and Leo wrote a program called tell
point which automatically actually
detects the size of the bands and
transfer to an excel sheet and so we can
actually make the calculations and I'm
not going to enter into the biology here
but the idea is that now we can actually
use the epsilon terms that we derived
from the results to try to put together
genes that seem to be acting in the same
way in the same category so this is what
we see here so for example you can
notice here that there are three genes
here that have essentially the same type
of interactions of storing yellow in
this scheme means epistatic interaction
that means they tend to work together
and blue means that they work separately
okay synergistic and so you can see that
these three mutants seems to have
essentially the same kind of interaction
with all the other mutants in the
collection and so what we can do from
here is look for stories for vertical
stories that we can go to the lab and do
the biochemistry and really see whether
they work together they interact
physically they are at the same place
etc etc and you can see that there are
several of these stories here or we can
go
sit back and look at the system and say
okay we know of about four different
ways maybe six if you separate this one
in two or this one in two ways different
ways in which telomere length can be
regulated or can be pretty this this
genes are in charge of preventing
elongation but delivers okay so this is
one of the efforts and at the other
thing that we can do also is look for
these magic squares so when you find a
magic square like this in which you have
a series of genes that have a pistachio
epistatic relations among themselves
okay so everybody with everybody is
yellow that probably means that we are
talking about it some kind of complex or
pathway okay so we are very interested
in understanding who are these genes and
what are they doing and how they're
doing it and so on okay so that was a
one story the other story is what we
call telka telomere length kinetics
analysis a sec sorry and this the idea
behind this essay to try to again we are
trying to take the 400 units and instead
of talking about 400 different entities
try to say okay we can talk about 10
different pathways or five different
pathways or three different passes or
whatever and so here the idea was to see
the basic idea is that if there are
genes that work together in a certain
path way you expect that the kinetics of
shortening or the kinetics of elongating
should be similar in the mutants of the
same pathway okay and so what what we
did was to create strains that are
heterozygous for the mutation okay so
they have one copy that is wild type 1
copy that is mutated because all these
mutations are recessive they deployed
that has both copies actually has normal
Cheevers and then we put these strains
to undergo meiosis and we get
descendants that are either mutant or
welded and the mutants they start at the
beginning once meiosis is free
ished they get a set of G of chromosomes
that have normal length telomers but
they are mutant so they will start to
shorten or that we send to elongate
according to what they should be showing
right and so we can follow them through
the generations and try to see what is
the kite sorry what is the kinetic the
kinetics of this event and what we found
out is that if you have mutants that
affect the same pathway you get very
similar kinetics and so we use this
trick to try to see if we can put
together mutants into categories
according to the kinetics of shortening
and I want go into all the details but
there was one group that was group
number three which was very small and it
was very striking and the striking thing
here was that at the first opportunity
in which we could measure telomere
length in this group the cells had
already attained the final size okay so
we take sales we take diploid cells we
put them through meiosis and then we
take once for and we just grow enough in
order to get DNA and when we get the DNA
the tumors are already at the final
length okay so that means that the
shortening is extremely sure extremely
fast and when we looked at who were the
genes in this category we got the cool
couple rni one and mid seven we know
that the cou couple is is a complex that
is very important for promoting DNA
repair in broken chromosomes and
preventing DNA repair in telomeres and
we got iron r1 and mid seven and met
seven was a gene that nobody knew what
it was doing we have no idea what they
were doing and so we we did biochemical
experiments to try to find out what they
did I'm not going to enter into all the
biology because it will be boring for
you but suffice to say that we we found
out who these proteins were and how they
were related to each other and what was
the mechanism that was being activated
so they work together we can demonstrate
that they can be both immunity
data together and one of them has a role
in DNA repair so they met seven the new
gene that we do know anything about
thanks to this methodology we could
associate it with cool and give it a
roll also in DNA repair okay so finally
I would like to talk about nature and
nurture and there are very few things
that we are certain about in life when a
one is taxes the other one is dead and
the third one apparently is that
telomeres is what makes you old right I
mean everybody knows that I I can read
it in cosmopolitan and you know every
time I talk to somebody and I said yeah
I work on Silver's I said ah ok so this
is what makes me old right so it's a
very well-known fact that telomeres get
short with age ok everybody knows that
and actually what nobody knows is that
the data behind that statement which is
the basis of companies I mean I used to
get this letter saying enlarge your
penis now it's enlarge your crop of
kilometres right and it's probably the
same pill I and so there are companies
that will tell you that they will tell
you when are you going to die according
to the measure of your chill immers ok
so this is an important stuff so the
basis for that is this paper here in
1998 which measured 12 individuals that
were newborns 24 that were their parents
35 that world grandparents and for the
word great-grandparents and found that
there is a correlation between telomere
lengths and age ok so the correlation is
is there however things are not so
simple and I the more we know the less
it appears to be that simple paradigm
and so for example now there is a paper
about the hundred thousand subjects into
which they measured telomeres and you
can see here that for women there is a
different a completely different curve
for women ok women the children's go
down with a
by the age of about thirty they stopped
shortening whereas men continue to start
to to shorten their genome ears until
the age of about 70 and here probably do
some kind of selection but I think that
most interests arresting is this paper
here that actually followed a bunch of
10,000 people in the Netherlands and
then they measure the telomeres with 10
years apart okay so this is the first
horizontal study in which they took one
person and measure each Steelers piece
or her two numbers ten years after okay
and this is the result okay you can see
that about half of the people the
telomeres got elongated half of the
people the tea lovers got shortened okay
moreover I think that this this is what
we should be showing everybody okay this
is the famous correlation now measuring
10,000 people so what you can see is
that indeed there is a correlation
between age and size the older you get
the lower the size of the Chilam is
right but II there are young people that
have shorter chillum ER than done old
people so just blindly taking a person's
telomere length and using it to decide
when he or she is going to die it's
impossible from this thing yes how
consistent is this across the cells okay
so all the experiments that we are
showing we're done with white blood
cells okay so we were trying to do it
with a brain but we couldn't get
volunteers to give your samples so it's
not it's not being done there is no data
whatsoever from any other tissue
you relate a question I mean so don't
cells probably were created from stem
cells not so long ago okay so I'm just
showing you know the things that have
been published and you can take you know
take home messages but what what started
our analysis was actually this paper
which really really struck me because
the the title of this paper was
accelerated to the were shortening in
response to psychological stress the
basic idea was they took a bunch of
people very very stressed and a bunch of
people very very non stressed and they
compared the tiamaris length and they
decided that that psychological stress
short and your children's ok so the
teleology behind this is quite simple
because if Silver's really get shortened
with age and people that are stressed
look older right now white hair and you
know you don't sleep and so on and so
makes sense right and for the graduate
students the very very stressed people
were not worthy students okay and the
non stress were not be ice but still I
mean I said this is very very weird okay
to do okay so we decided to use yeast
cells because we can do with them what
we want and so we we said okay let's
take all the different ways that we can
imagine of stressing yeast cells not
psychologically because I have no idea
how to do that but we can actually
stress the cells in the sense that we
can make them grow I mean use a stress
that makes them grow slowly and so we
use a series of all the possible
stresses that we could think about and
when we apply that to to each sales okay
so this is work initiated by gallant
I'll and continued by Annie this is your
Neil notice and vera and what we found
out is that most of the stresses don't
do absolutely anything but there are
some stresses that do have an effect for
example cafe in will shorten your
telomeres and ethanol with lengthen your
children's
so now you know how to balance your life
right so this is the data actually what
you can see here is that it's not only
ethanol most alcohols will elongate the
telomeres but Ethan all is the one that
works better okay you can see here every
time you see the arrow that's the
wild-type and you can see that ethanol
methanol is a propanol ethanol all of
them elongate the two demers acetic acid
will do something similar cafe with
shorten your telomeres and get an also
high temperature and hydrogen hydrogen
peroxide which is a oxidative damage
which was the interpretation of the
psychological stress so that what they
said is that psychological stress causes
oxidative stress in the cells and that
is what is shortening your two numbers
we don't do anything okay so at least
for yeast we don't see any effect of of
either of oxidative stress and if you
add caffeine what you see is that with
the with the generations you see a
shortening of the children's which does
not get to the lower possible length but
it gets to a plateau and if you wash the
caffeine away the cells returns slowly
to the normal size so this is not a
mutation that you are selecting for this
is a physiological response to the
presence of caffeine or ethanol so with
ethanol they defeat the image is very
very different what you can see here is
that the cells start with short tunable
normal to rumors and then as low as long
as you keep adding ethanol to the
culture the key levers get longer and
longer but also you can see that the
variability is larger and larger which
means that the mechanism that chooses
the short telomers to be the ones that
get elongated is lost and you actually
now elongate everybody and so you get
this last meal yes so you're talking
about like not the molecular mass you
think the monarchy the molecular mass is
staying the same but the physical length
is shrinking is that I'm yes I'm
measuring the telomere length of each of
each country's so telomers
kept growing we have now strains that
have 10 and 20 fold longer telomeres
than the normal well tied without any
effect that we can measure so we can do
for a competition experiments between
the long telomeres and the normal
settlements we don't see any difference
okay so this is actually a very great
situation to be in because we have now
at least you know of all the possible
genes that affect a certain trait and
also we have environmental signals that
affect the same trade so we can actually
try to see how the environment and the
genes interact so the famous need nature
and nurture or environment and genes we
can actually start probing how it works
so what we did was to measure the
expression of all the deals under the
different conditions and then the basic
idea is that if the environment is
sending some signal and the cells are
responded to the stew that signal by
elongating or shortening the telomeres
the tlm jeans should be in the in the in
the middle right because these are the
genes that cause elongation or
shortening of telomeres so we can ask if
we make a mutation in one tlm gene will
it interrupt the signal let's say if I
grow all my collection of tlm mutants in
the presence of ethanol will I see
mutants that don't elongate anymore
they're cheaters and when we did that
what we found out is that in general so
what we are seeing here is what is the
initial length of the various strains
and what is the elongation after 100
generations or what is the shortening
after hundred generations and you can
see that the genes actually elongate the
mutants elongate in response to ethanol
or shortening respond to caffeine in a
way that is proportional to the
phenotype that they have without the
distress that means that each one is
contributing whatever it can write and
so we are looking for things that are
outside of this range and the clear
winner is brief one so r if one is a
mutant that has very low
chido mares but does not respond to it
at all almost natick almost that does
not elongate or does not shorten with
Kaffee so to make a very long story
short and again I don't want to bore you
with all the biochemistry what we found
is that ethanol causes a reduction in
rap one rap on is the enza the protein
that binds the T domus actually serves
as a ruler to measure the length of the
Chilam ears and because of that we have
less reef one and reef 22 in the in the
cinemas and if you replace the promoter
of a frap one by a promoter that does
not respond anymore to ethanol okay you
can see here that ethanol does not
change it then instead of this response
you get now this response so actually
it's very important for the cells are
responding to the presence of ethanol
bye-bye actually reducing the amount of
of rap1 so this is our model ok so in
normal cells you have a certain length
which is kept if you have a very short
chill Amir now the cells are trying that
they count how many rap proteins they
have and according to the number of
proteins they have they recruit more and
more a telomerase and in the indicates
that in the presence of ethanol they
have very few wrap one but they don't
know it and so they keep so the tillers
are long but they keep bringing
telomerase and elongating more and more
and in the last minute I have so please
join me in a prayer in the last minute I
have I would like to tell you about
something very very cool that we are
doing now these days in here in Berkeley
it has to do with heterochromatin
chromatin and so it may interest you one
of the problems that we found is that we
don't actually have a very good way of a
functional way of establishing of
reading a traumatic situations so we can
actually do all these genome-wide
experiments nuclear arms Easton's things
like that and see their modifications
but we don't have actually a very good
reader and the
the laboratory of Jasper Rhine has
developed a very very cool thing that I
just wanted to tell you in one minute so
that you know it's called the crash SI
and it's based on the following a
principal in the East cell we have
silencing that means etro chromatic
regions in the chromosome at the
telomeres and also at to silent
cassettes one that is called HML and the
other one that is called HMR and this is
mediated by the set elation of Easton
for at the cave 16 and the sir two
complexes sirtuins are actually the ones
that are in charge of establishing that
silencing and so what they did was to
replace one of the genes in the silent
cassette by a Cree recombinase so the
career communist knows how to recognize
this loxp cassette and they inserted a
somewhere in the genome and rfp gene
bracketed by the two loxp cassettes so
if this gene is if this gene is silence
there is no cree recombinase and the
cells are red however if the sensor
bread however if the Cree becomes even
transiently expressed so if the
repression on the chromatin is lifted
even for for a minute we will get
expression of Cree combination that will
turn the cells from red to green and
this is how it looks so if you have a
wild-type sale it's mainly red and you
have very few sectors of green so these
sectors are actually because the first
sale here and there went the switch and
then all its descendants actually we're
already switched okay and we can now
take these cells and use a couple of use
mutants okay essentially we can use all
the yeast mutants to try to see how they
affect the ATO chromatic state and you
can see for example that this my
favorite muta the LG one has a huge
amount of this
switching whereas there are others that
have a very very low amount of switching
okay and this is what I wanted to tell
you and so finally I would like to thank
the people in the lab and this was a
collaboration with people from the
School of Computer Sciences in Tel Aviv
University a brunch a mere raja cholan
and eaten group in and thank you for
your attention
so all the lengthening and shortening in
response to those stresses yeast I
totally understand I'm trying to relate
it back to the human context I thought
you were saying that we don't have
active plumber is in somatic cells so no
amount of drinking alcohol is going to
lengthen those feeling airship okay
first of all I would like to tell you
that we tried to put alcohol and
caffeine into our human cells and they
died okay so it's not a simple thing
because I mean we are using amounts that
are absolutely irrelevant to the human
you know behavior for sure that so
essentially you know you're like they're
talking about regulation of how fast
they get short not so much so most
people don't talk about anything
significant they actually are talking
about that what they measure which is a
PCR reaction that is also problematic on
white blood cells which we don't know
when where they create it because they
are renewed all the time is part of our
blood okay so it's very hard to know
exactly what that means okay that and
but there is a correlation which we
don't really know the meaning of between
age and size that can be measured in
that way okay most of our cells express
very very very low levels of telomerase
and it's only the embryonic stem cells
the ones that are actually expressing
telomerase and so they are able to cope
with whatever change is needed
ok maybe we continue to discussing
outside ok great